Chef Elisa Reynolds classically trained
soul food raised and I'm on a mission we
searching for soul food let's get it
[Music]
my restaurant in La I apply my classical
training to what I know
soul food
Cuisine created with Ingenuity through
struggle that nourished my people
through its hardest times and I think
just maybe we aren't the only ones with
that bomb ass formula what do you guys
think coming in for a second yay so I'm
ready to taste the soul of the rest of
the world and I'm bringing you along for
the journey Peru Jamaica South Africa
y'all and I feel like I just tapped into
the soul of Napoli Mamma Mia people say
la has a lot of flavor and no soul I beg
to differ it's about making something
out of nothing with sustenance and love
in every bite and I want to get a taste
of it all not now
we're trying to do here is like let
people know
the depth within these meals whenever I
sit down at a table it brings back those
memories from when I was little it is
the oldest Mississippi in South Africa
what and how long has this tradition
been going on 8
000 years
when I eat soul food it takes me all the
way back to like the happiest times of
my life when you have love in your food
that's what everybody's coming for this
is history on a plate
[Music]